-Right now, though,
if you guys don't mind,
do you mind if I write out
some thank-you notes right now?
Is that cool with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James -- James, can I get some
thank you note
writing music, please?
♪♪
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, he's -- he's psyched.
-Yeah.
-Guess he's got a couple
Red Bulls before the show.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Eee!
♪♪
-Thank you, new speaker
of the House Mike Johnson,
for being the first person
to win an election
with the slogan,
"You've seen the best.
Now vote for the rest."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Come on.
Why not?
-Why not, man?
♪♪
-Thank you, Reese's Pieces,
for making me see
which one of my friends
can't pronounce Reese's.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Oh, "Reesie's."
-Reese's.
-"Reesie's" Piece --
"Reesie's Piecies."
-"Reese's Piecies."
-Reese's Pieces.
-Reesie's Piecies feces.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
walking through a spider web,
for turning me
into a black belt in karate.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa!
♪♪
-Thank you, TikTok's
planned music festival,
for promising to be
a fun gathering of people
staring at their phones
for five hours.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Frankenstein,
for looking like the Hulk
after dealing with Spectrum
customer service.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Wow.
-What?
-Spectrum?
Are you gonna send that
to Frankenstein?
-I have no idea.
-So you're thanking
Frankenstein with that?
-I don't know
who I'm thanking again.
Am I thanking the Hulk?
-Thanking Frankenstein.
-Oh, wait.
I'm thanking Frankenstein.
-Yeah, Frankenstein.
-He looks like --
Because he looks like the Hulk
after dealing with
Spectrum customer --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, man.
-You got to put it
in the mail, right?
-Hey, man, you got to do it.
-Yeah. Come on, Frank.
-Come on, man.
Come on, Frank.
-Frankie.
-Frankie boy.
-Come on, boy!
You been dealing
with Spectrum customer service!
-Whoo-ooh!
[ Laughter ]
-Are you going to send
that one?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-That other one,
you're gonna send it in?
-The other one?
Uh, yeah, maybe.
I might send it in,
I might not.
I don't even know at this point.
-Just checking.
-I don't know.
Thanks for checking, though.
-Well, I want to make sure
you're okay.
-Yeah, I will.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, "It's the
Great Pumpkin, Charlie Brown,"
for the scariest moment
in any "Peanuts" special,
when you realize Sally is
just Charlie Brown in a wig.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-What?
[ Applause ]
-[ Imitating "Peanuts" teacher
speaking ]
-Probably Linus and Lucy.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you,
fun-size candy,
for being the short kings
of the chocolate world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-Wow!
Big fans of short kings.
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
-Thank you, candy corn,
for being the most delicious way
to eat a candle.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.